welcome back these two gentlemen who
show just keep getting bigger and bigger
every single time we have them back in
the tenth season of NBC's American Ninja
Warrior airing every single Monday
including tonight at 8:00 Eastern and
Pacific we've got Matt Iseman and Akbar
Bobby Emily good to see you guys yep so
um Akbar yeah since we last saw one
another yep
you had a physical feat that we saw
yeah I actually competed on Celebrity
Ninja Warrior that's correct yet that's
not what big talking about okay anything
else that you want I was just at the
Raiders training camp how did the
Raiders look they look amazing Jon
Gruden seriously no he's intense and the
attention to detail and even just when I
saw the martavis bryant over there in
kent oh my goodness I think he's gonna
get the most out of martavis bryant and
and I'm sure you're right cuz you're
you're always on target I mean you're
you always hit you always hit your spot
I mean I do feel the build-up well I
mean look uh Reggie Mackenzie and Jon
Gruden that you know I was messing
around in the field I got my hand in the
dirt but I didn't have the same type of
get off is that the athletic that you're
talking about no no no okay that could
be okay talking about Philadelphia
Pennsylvania
oh and we will get to your wonderful
show and the charitable contributions
that your show is is bringing to the
floor okay we'll get to that in a second
okay but your first pitch ceremonial
first pitch in Philadelphia boy okay oh
yeah I mean can I explain this the
floors the floors yours radio audience
we're seeing okay so don't pay attention
to the throw I want you to pay attention
to the legs look at look at my leg yes
my right leg goes up and that was paying
homage to dinners accuracy whoo I grew
up watching Orel Hershiser I grew up
watching those pitchers and but I didn't
play baseball
you remember Darryl Strawberry was the
last thing
last baseball player to come out of my
neighborhood and and I came that was a
good okay so here's what happened I was
like okay throwing out the first pitch
it's not big deal I've thrown a baseball
before you gonna cross the shoulder
where that's showing a base one thing
it's not throwing a pitch is not that
hard sure and so the night before I
don't warm up I don't watch anything I
said you know actually let me just
YouTube and the first thing it pops up
is Barack Obama and then George W Bush
and I watch them and they do this old
man over the head throw and I was like
oh no there's no way in hell I'm gonna
go out there and look I'm 39 I'm gonna
look like a fool oh dude and I'm a
little sensitive because I'm 39 now in
my almost 40 and I'm like I don't want
to be that guy so I said you know I'm
gonna show everybody that look I still
got some athlete left in me yeah and so
I go out there and I'm like first of all
I'm look at the mountain my wife I'm out
so far from the whole place actually on
the dirt because I was trying to cheat
it I mean I'm Alma grass because I'm
trying to cheat it yeah so I wanted to
get a little closer so I said I got this
so I was confident in my throat and in
the build-up and then I put the leg up
and everything look I'm on the grass and
if you give him credit he did hold the
runner at first base you know you guys
are talking about what
the grass there and I thought I was
gonna be able to make that pitch and I
wanted a little zine yeah I wasn't try
to do too much if I could get like 60 75
miles an hour I was gonna be good yes
and it didn't it didn't work that way no
it didn't my favorite aspect of this
because I've only watched it about a
thousand times
so all those YouTube personally I've
personally made it a considerable
multiplier is not only the reaction of
the Philly Phanatic who made like some
sort of perfect sort of comic TT you
with your comments okay
it is fantastic but then you are you are
left with no choice Akbar except to
mutter something towards a mascot you
actually you approach to the don't let
me do that again let me do you ask for a
mulligan yeah and they were like no you
have to lay in there like pointy like
you have this you have to go home the
crazy part was I'm listening to all the
Bulls blew and I'm feeling honored I'm
like oh man shoot like mama made it like
and then the boos that came out was like
oh man this is bad really boo Santa
Claus definitely when I got outside of
the stadium my phone was blowing up I'm
my own man but here's the most
embarrassing part of it all yes
or the part that kind of hurt me my dad
calls me and he saw it and he's living
up in Green Bay with my brother and he
calls me he goes he calls me Kimmy goes
Kimmy why did you invite nasty family
like that and I'm sitting there Mike
anyway you get the accent of embarass
it's not embarrassed you embarrass us
you embarrass the family emphasis on the
last syllable
what a Kabir say did he say anything oh
he just laughed he yeah he just laughed
Kabir by the way it comes out to
American Ninja Warrior
mr. season seven yeah first time Kabir
comes out in flip flops takes a look at
the Warped wall goes can I try it
we're like yeah if you want to get any
just turns runs up it on his very first
attempt in flip flops it took me like I
had to learn from flip Rodriguez but
guess what that's why he's a better man
Iseman Akbar Bosh I'll be a Miller here
in the Rich Eisen show I do remember you
know back in my day when I was doing a
lot of stuff which Stewart and I was a
team yeah I was a broadcasting team that
anytime Stewart would do anything people
would ask me like what's up what's up
okay so I asked you you're a team with
Akbar did people say I played baseball
in college and so Akbar asked me for
some tips the night before yellow and I
and I said you know here's a couple tips
I go but if you really want to make an
impact tank it
I said Oh bro nobody will notice a
strike yeah buddy mr. Sandt mariah carey
those are the legendary Baba Booey I
haven't even heard of these these bachas
I heard a fifty-cent cuz that was big
but I hadn't heard these but I told him
I said I'm an athlete like the pride of
it is that I can't just go out there and
throw a bad pitch so I dismissed that
and go I'm going to actually go up there
and throw a pitch because for me that's
like a fancy oh did you see my first
pitch like yeah I threw a Dennis
Eckersley type strike and it came right
back I love it all right let's take a
60-second break we'll come back we'll
talk about actual feats and what
Akbar Bobby amel and Matt Iseman we'll
talk about Oriole back in a minute
all right welcome back to the show
my kids can't get enough of it that's
it's so great to see you guys here Matt
Iseman and Akbar Bobby Miller because I
feel like you're in my home on my nine
seventy four-year-old you cannot get
enough just pop up to the house right
well by the way if you ever did that
they would answer much yeah we should
set up some obstacle courses in the back
oh my guys just do the and we'll just
start calling it from like the side
fence or whatever test what is that
available for but now that's but there
is gonna be a kids iteration yes
Universal Universal kids that's gonna be
on universal kids Wii it's gonna come
out this fall October 13th
ages 9 to 14 and so they'll be competing
at age groups 9 & 10 11 12 13 14
so is there a mega Warped wall for
theirs yeah well the Warped wall it's
it's 13 feet for these kids and and
what's amazing is so we just we were
just out there and we saw without giving
anything away we saw people 4 feet tall
getting up this warped wall and and the
the amazing thing is the athleticism of
these kids the strength to weight ratio
and the fearlessness of them was we was
remarkable because I think people are
kind of in their head when they hear kid
Ninja Warrior they think of it being
something like an inflatable core no I
think it's it's it's hardcore it's
hardcore it looks it feels it is the
same type of obstacle course that we
have set up for the for the main show
for American Ninja Warrior and to see
these little bodies going through these
obstacles and they're racing against
each other as well so they're not only
racing against the course they're racing
against each other and the intensity
level that these kids have I mean it is
totally different than what you see on
the the regular show so it's good I
can't wait for this to come out on your
personal kids now is there like a Lavar
ball type we really what's cool is we
actually have some parents who've
competed on there right but we didn't
hear anybody telling these kids to stay
in their Lane
- shut up our friend Christine
helicopter dad your mom no no big
ballers uh you know t-shirts are brands
for the kids they just what I think
parents will have a difficult time you
know with kids sports but one of the
cool things about Ninja Warrior is and
we see with this sports so much of it
isn't about it's not about being the
best or it's about going the farthest
it's it's not even even though we had
them going head-to-head it really this
this is such a positive sport in the
sense of you're really competing against
yourself and so that's the messaging for
this show is just you don't have to hit
a buzzer to win right like with Kenny
nee metallo this guy who's whose child
is alive because of being on this show I
think whether he completes a course or
not he's gonna say that's the biggest
victory I've got and again he's on
tonight and just to recount the story is
that the fact that he was on the show
and the fact that his daughter needed a
kidney transplant and got it based on
somebody who just said you know we were
yeah it's the gift that keeps giving if
you were just decided to see if yeah if
it was a she was this girl I believe her
name was Amy and like the unbelievable
generosity of someone to offer up you
know again that's what's great if you go
to kidney org slash living donor
you can donate organs as a person stayin
alive this is and the beauty is that
he's back at it doing it again and this
time for another kid's life and so it's
been pretty cool to see that and it'd be
great that next year the story is that
that kid found a kidney donor it would
be great but you realized to the
magnitude of the show that someone out
there is watching for they're not only
watching they're actively participating
in somebody's call for help right now
maybe they can they can grow up be
healthy and compete in the children yeah
and that would be amazing you know it
would be amazing it's just like Tom
house or a great pitching coach we're
watching right now right he could reach
out and help this guy that would be an
amazing story
you understand I did not go back yeah
I'm a lefty I was supposed to do better
anyways I digress yeah right yeah
so um and again I told you guys this in
the back the part of the reason why it's
obviously so successful is it's it's
just crazy to see the feats of strength
and the ideas of of what the course is
looks like but the stories that you
learn of these folks and it is so family
friendly I don't feel like my kids are
gonna be assaulted by yeah something out
of nowhere that I have to sit there and
explain what's what well they're like
like you know myself you you like I mean
they're ordinary people that are out
there that they watch these shows and
they they're not looking at these super
superhero athletes like you're LeBron
James that you guys are talking about
earlier these are ordinary people doing
extraordinary things on these
extraordinary obstacles like American
Ninja Warrior is the hardest obstacle
course in the world and it's that way
for a reason but when you see your
accountant or your teacher your fifth
grade teacher who's crushed in the
course and who has an amazing story or
somebody who's overcoming cancer and
they're stepping on the course for the
first time fresh off a chemotherapy like
that means something and I think our
executive producers they do a great job
of telling great stories and connecting
the fans to to the athletes who comes up
with the course we it goes on year-round
we have a group of people who are
developing these obstacles we actually
some of our best obstacles have come
from fans we if if fans want to say it
obstacles we have an obstacle design
challenge where they can create
obstacles we've had so the best
obstacles were a seven-year-old a
nine-year-old an eleven-year-old did it
in crayon
yeah and submitted obstacles are you
serious yeah and we have the double
viper in las vegas this this like
Santa's sleigh ride thing that was
created by this 11 year old girl in
California and it's just amazing the
creativity for these young kids and
what's been great too is for a lot of
them like again this guys six six to
sixty as a 1650 now he's trimmed down
has a six pack yes this is the guy who
plays in the NFL and for for most of us
for most people at home that may never
be them but for a lot of these kids
they've now found a sport where they can
excel where anyone any body type
you can come out and work to your
strengths or be a little leaner on the
smaller side right and really excel and
show you to have this unbelievable
athletic ability oh damn
so what's the have you ever successfully
negotiated an American Ninja Warrior
course Akbar Bob well I did I did it for
the celebrity for the celebrity version
I did it and that was pretty amazing I
did five of the six obstacles and it was
very nervous to my chest was like tight
I'm like I don't think I could do this
right but I realize after running the
celebrity version I realized that all of
my calls are gonna have a respect at the
end of the of the calls just because I
know the optics of it just running on
something and knowing that there's
nothing worse than knowing that there's
water beneath and if you fall you fail
and that it is the ultimate sign of I
felt I'm wet I'm uncomfortable everybody
seeing me and for those athletes to
compete under those conditions it's
really like in football like look it's
happened to me before
like you do something you get blasted
maybe not everybody see it like when
you've done something athletic that
didn't work out well and you were
embarrassed you can throw a great first
pitch but the Dodgers came right through
a strike right for the Scott Boras try
but but against the Mets I I don't think
I'll be signed and Akbar you you're
doing some with the Michael J Fox
foundation that you are on the board of
correct yes that's right what is this
all about well so Jimmy Choi who's one
of our competitors he competes with
Parkinson's disease and last two years
ago he competed for the first time and
it was one of those things that was
amazing to see someone compete my father
has Parkinson's disease and he's been
battling that since 1998 and I wanted to
do something to where I could
the two together so bringing essentially
Ninja Warrior parkour and Parkinson's
together so I'm having my very first
fundraiser event this weekend
August 5th which is gonna be from 1 p.m.
to 6 p.m. at dojo boom in Thousand Oaks
California you can get tickets at
team-fox org slash Akbar
but we're gonna have a lot of the top
ninjas out there they're gonna come out
and help folks be a ninja so you can
come out there and you're gonna learn
from some of the best ninjas out there
kids of all ages can come out and have
fun there's a trampoline park one of the
premier trampoline and ninja where you
train it's where I train for celebrity
Ninja Warrior as well so it is going to
be a big time event and we're looking to
weight raise $350,000 but this all was
jumped off by me watching a guy by the
name of Jimmy Choi he works with the
Michael J Fox foundation it inspired me
to do something with my platform so I
wanted to go on and so I've joined on as
a board member of the Michael J Fox
foundation and it's gonna be cool I
think it's gonna be a lot of fun I want
to do something different I don't want
to just have a celebrity event I wanted
to do something like Ninja Warrior bring
family and community together to raise
money so that's on Sunday I'll be I'll
be coming back from the Hall of Fame so
I'll could unfortunately be the tio of
this accept your invitation
declined to appear maybe you can donate
a teen spot to that or it's a great
cause yeah I would do that okay all
right I would absolutely say there's a
great cause yeah do you guys want to
chime in on the poll question I heard
you guys have one to chime in on the
poll well you know I was on Celebrity
Apprentice with the boss Schwarzenegger
so if you were talking about
Schwarzenegger his favorite movie there
there really is you know we Terminator 2
of course is one of the greatest but the
correct answer is you can't choose just
one every one of these movies is the
basketball but if I do it is a fresh no
predator predator I'm gonna go with the
one that people don't talk about all the
time that isn't Total Recall great one
okay those are those are two options
along with True Lies t2 and my favorite
the Running Man 2017 we was running
there was sent into this dystopian
fashion
we're now a year passed when I was on
apprentice he pointed out I go do you
realize you've become Damon Killian
you're the host I'm Ben Richards this is
very deep running man quoting it who do
you love he quoted me that he quoted him
to me which was a highlight but if I'm
not mistaken though that's the Rhett's
of richard dawson line it was a richard
dawson I'm a running man nerd that was
an oh that's Jim Brown just run sure
what was it was pre the mind venture he
was still what's the results the
Terminator 2 is leading right now 33%
predator 28 percent 20% True Lies 14
percent Total Recall and only five
percent running people just haven't seen
running yeah running meerkat was was
under the radar yeah it's a good it was
very predictive I think of a potential
future that hopefully we'll avoid but it
didn't say how important gameshow hosts
are NBC to correct yeah I mean without
what it's what was that a drop this is
do it 70 71 today huh still it looks
great unbelievable shape I'm still mad
that his last name is longer than mine
yeah he's got 14 letters at 12 but my
full name is 32 letters just if anyone
cared bad your first pitch one back to
that when we come back to the television
audience we're gonna really hit that or
at that hard what you see it wait for it
wait for it
you've won 8:00 p.m. Eastern and Pacific
Monday night tenth season of NBC
American Ninja Warrior I couldn't be
happier for you guys it's so much just
in the midst of a juggernaut it's Earth
Emmy nomination - I know
reality-competition program yeah yeah
it's awesome it really really is great
thanks Matt Iseman
in Akbar baja be a Miller here we'll set
up the rest of the week when we come
back do it do it come on the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience